ein handy-video aus dem bahnhofsviertel
in frankfurt hat deutschland geschockt
ein mann wird von einer gruppe umzingelt
mit voller wucht ins gesicht geschlagen
er knallt mit dem kopf auf das pflaster
bleibt bewusstlos liegen und wird
ausgeraubt jetzt kam es laut bild
informationen zu einer ersten festnahme
nach und zweiwöchigen ermittlungen
klickten am dienstagabend gegen 22 uhr
bei einem bulgaren die handschellen es
handelt sich offenbar um den mann der
das opfer so brutal gegen den kopf
geschlagen haben soll er wurde bereits
ein haftrichter vorgeführt und sitzt
jetzt in u haft der vorwurf lautete raum
[Musik]